hello everybody my name is markiplier
into the maintenance tunnel we go you
know I'm playing you know what I'm doing
I don't even tell you anymore so we're
just gonna charge right into this blind
completely no warning and no care for
our own safety that's what we're gonna
do and that's where all we're always
meant to do I forgot to turn up my
volume a bit
oh joy okay I love the tunnels I love
everything about the maintenance tunnel
their circular shape the way they
represent the my god
oh is that what happened see in front of
me looking for a big it in front of me
I took it in front of me you dick out
after you get in front of me you Boosh
oh why can't I have like a single candle
or a flashlight or something anything to
keep the dark okay
oh he's coming through the middle of the
news yeah
ah you're blocking our buyers that I
gotta go all the way around you [ __ ]
okay uh that's new the hell is that we
left where did I go oh okay come on yeah
will you dick with me oh you okay we're
not moving wait a minute milling does
that sound
Oh
how we go I did it I did it guys I did
add on the greatest and the greatest
there ever was
okay so I'm over here with the STP
douche wacker 682 or whatever his name
is I just got to make my so dark why my
I don't have my mask oh no just
wondering if really dark and I don't
know why I can't see a bloody thing okay
there we go
it's like extra dark as it were oh you
do yep
yup
ah not this time Indiana Jones
what is it sound it's new
what the hell is going on here what is
that what is that I read about that
looks familiar maybe just cuz it's the
math well I think we found a new recipe
let's find out what to do what does it
do how do I get in it got a skeleton key
will that help
yep voodoo ski not now what everything
ah gas valves door oh thank god someone
actually found me what relief uni throws
it safely to the surface just find a
control panel in there and open the
chamber doors for me
why wrong at you wrong you know I can
either kill him what'd you do
how did you get if you get over there oh
I see I see we did ah dude do you have a
mask on your face you have a little mask
going on here is that I'm gonna be a
problem for me so I either kill you
alright I admit it I wouldn't blame you
if you don't think I look trustworthy
but please I need your help
oddly the masks been stuck to my face
for some time now from the inside okay
yeah all right okay I trust you I trust
you completely you are a cool dude I
trust you what's up this is where we
part ways yeah the sake of my freedom I
have reason to believe that scp-079 is
taking control of the facility systems
including the door system the best bet
is to appeal to it somehow hopefully you
can come to a compromise however it does
not control the warheads but you should
disable remotely in the event that
something goes wrong
ah no no you know you miss go you go ah
pissing balls aren't I'm gonna try to
see what else I could have done in that
situation all right I'm back you [ __ ]
well well well haha yeah
what came across there I'll give you one
more chance here
just open the chamber doors and we'll
forget about this little gas incident
how about nope Oh does that work no okay
all right friend
that never happened with me able to the
sake of my freedom the simplest way for
you to get out safely is to go and find
a cp0 one to apply containment zone
between the lines it'll be as
interpreter balls and map good luck
thank you I guess I'm not sure what the
hell just happened there you're gonna be
a cool bro dude man
I'm really not sure what the hell
happened there all right never mind
gonna go the other way are you all right
forget I went that way okay oh good oh
good for you
that never turns out well for that guy
always a little disturbing that seems to
happen
I'll come on isn't there a way I can get
through oh there we go oh I hate this
part I hate this part a lot where is it
I don't know where oh no oh I hate this
part hey hey looking at the ground
didn't seem to help either where's this
go just go
no vision I fell ah come on
no salvation only death okay take two on
that one doors open don't open don't
open that door cuz it just leads to
nothingness not looking at I'm not
looking at you Oh not looking at you
oh oh oh oh oh oh god get out of here oh
god oh fuel on I don't know what this do
I don't know what I do
Oh
did I make it did I mannequin this room
I made it hey I saved a better a friggin
made it come on you're killing me smalls
again again this with these doors with
access codes to I never find the access
hi whatever let's do this again same old
same old
make a left this time you know like you
me no today oh god no not the zom zoms
it was something I needed to know okay
never mind I'm just gonna keep going
through you and your face and I'm out of
here baby in it nothing to do with them
I can save my sorry skin the expense of
everybody else in this entire world why
do I keep hearing that he's not here is
he
no no of course
huh what are you doing to me
my brain broken is Billy here
anybody seen Billy Billy Billy okay I'm
in the office area now all right I
wonder when nine-tailed Fox is gonna get
in here okay sorry
do come on [ __ ] me dick dick bag okay
we'd prefer not to go down that way
Paisley prefer not to
I'm never gonna be able to find my way
back
2:07 - he was all the way at the
beginning was this oh this is gate B
okay that's where that's where the guy
could let me out for the long gotta okay
oh come on
well I seem to be in a bit of a pickle
ah okay no we're here the office areas
got lost in the maze of offices SCPs
containment douche bags are
Oh
hi
no how about nope
how about no man no no Oh what were you
doing up there yeah what everybody okay
so he's up here and he's not exactly
friendly is he up here still yeah where
is he well oh there is ah that fair
who's is fair what is this dessert I'm
so bummed I can't look at the thing I
need to turn my third what am i got out
oh no you two fight do do get out with
supremacy I'll let Billy kill me before
you you [ __ ] your fish where are you I
bet even better I don't want to go into
your pocket dimension you douche nozzle
what the hell is this like the room of
nightmares they don't want me to turn
off the power
okay maybe if I summon Billy to this
room and make it a bit easier Billy
Billy okay I'm gonna assume you're nice
in down there
all tucked away in your from befores
then I'm gonna go up here in confidence
that you are not there you dick right
right what the hell
where is he Grisi
I don't see him I don't stand my dosti
was there before oh there you are okay I
got
what happened was my blinked I'm about
to go so I have no choice he's gonna
appear here he's like ah come on what
the hell okay I can get in here I can do
this I can do this oh goodness I can do
this I can do this I can do this where
is he where is he where is he where is
Billy that was a delayed reaction that
was a delayed reaction
okay that was like okay I'm a last time
I'm Way over something I don't know go
either way
ah go thank you all so much for watching
Kilty empties from morphing here's that
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye
is it is users left teleportation no
that's actually something there there is
something there
that is a thing nada there's the thing
man don't worry seismic gradual recent
times faster back achieving this would
meet a great economist framing they
become a model with yours I have these
all the through time feasible